Hey, this is Emily Valani and
I'm calling from Austin, Texas.
Radiolab is supported
by dash digital cash,
a revolutionary form of money that allows
anyone anywhere to make instant secure
payments. Dash is digital
cash. For more information,
visit [inaudible] dot org slash radio lab.
It's good to hear this. I'm like,
I'm Jad Roberts, Radiolab and this
[inaudible].
Oh, I can die. A happy man. So
that was perfect. So here we go.
This is radio lab. I'm Jad Abumrad
and I'm Robert Krulwich and this
sound of 700 people who have come to
bear witness to the recording of our show
today. We are in the Fitzgerald
Theater at Saint Paul,
Minnesota talking about these strange
phenomenon that is the war of the worlds.
Know I, it's very great that
everybody's here, of course. But this,
there is one guy I really
wish had been here. Who?
That the Ecuadorian Guy Leonardo.
Well, let's just, yeah, yeah,
because he's the guy I want to
ask. Like, what were you thinking?
That's what I want. Well, he's
dead. He's dead. Yeah. Well,
but how Orson Welles, I would say to
him, what, what were you thinking?
I would say dead. Yeah. Yeah. How
about the guy in Buffalo Buffalo?
A missing retired? I don't know.
That's ask somebody. So I found a
guy who I think is definitely alive.
I am Daniel Myrick, Cole writer,
Co Director of the Blair witch project
before making the Blair witch project and
my Rick heard a recording
of the war of the worlds,
which he was pretty young at
the time. He was a teenager.
I just thought it was brilliant.
I absolutely the coolest thing
and more than anything else,
he was impressed by the
technique of the thing.
There's a couple of moments in particular
where they cut to the kind of onsite
reporter return you to call
fill ups that drover's. Yeah,
it's almost like cut in a second or two
early and you hear the reporters saying,
so are we on my arm? Are we, are
we going to ladies and gentlemen?
And then he goes into his into character.
Here I am back with stone wall
and it's those little beats,
those little moments that
really make it convincing.
I get this kind of guilty excitement when
I, when I know how it affected people.
Myrick never forgot that sense
of guilty, uh, excitement.
He was fascinated by the idea that scary
stories get even scarier if you think
they're true. So years later,
fresh out of film school,
he and his friend Eduardo Sanchez
decided to develop their own, uh,
wells like product. It's your basic scary,
which story three a kids go into
the woods. Okay, okay, okay,
we're leaving right now. They get lost.
They bump into the witch and then they
die. Or they think they die. You'll just,
you never see them again.
But when you entered the theater
to see the Blair witch project,
the first thing that you'd see on
the screen are these two sentences.
It would read in October of 1994,
three student filmmakers disappeared
in the woods near Burkittsville,
Maryland while shooting a
documentary. A year later,
their footage was found.
So the suggestion here is that what we
see is not a movie within our mind that
you are in a movie theater, right?
And you're paid $10 and have some
popcorn. Yeah. Yeah. But when you went,
when you went sat down,
what you saw was something called the
found footage shot by three kids who have
gone missing. And so these
kids, you're not sure,
but they might be real. Well,
we picked a subject matter
that was difficult to disprove
to the Casual Observer
Martians invading from outer space is
you turn the channel to the next network
and if no one's reporting about
it, it's pretty well assured.
It's probably fiction, but three
missing students in the woods, you know,
that's something that is a little harder
to disprove without a fair amount of
scrutiny. And it worked.
We were getting calls from
police wondering where these
three kids were and how
come they never heard of this
case? You're kidding. Oh yeah.
I mean it was constant. Oh people,
we saw the whole thing and thought
they saw something real. Still do.
I still getting emails occasionally on
what part of the story is real, you know,
is there still any phenomena out
in Burkittsville and [inaudible]?
It's all fiction and is all made up.
And I think it reinforces what I think
Ed and I suspected that so much of us
wants to believe.
Some people told Dan Myrick that after
watching the sweet campers go in the
woods, they themselves would
never go camping again.
And he thought that was fabulous. He
loved [inaudible], blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. Well, why would
you not want people to go camping?
I mean, we know honestly, why would you
do that to people? I asked him. Well,
I think that's the goal of any
filmmaker. When you make a movie,
whether you want people to
laugh or cry or be scared,
you're trying to affect
people so viscerally and so
emotionally that it has a
resonating effect on them long after
they've seen your movie. And I mean,
that's why you're doing it. You know,
we're not making this movie
to kind of scare people.
We were making the film
to really scare people.
Okay.
No regrets on people not wanting
to go camping afterwards.
So the question is, is that what
Orson Welles was up to back in 1938?
Was he just trying to give people a
good old fashion show business scare,
make them scream away, up in the
balcony? Because remember at the time,
that is what he claimed, that
this was simply an entertainment.
This is awesome. Well,
ladies and gentleman out of character
to assure you that the war of the worlds
has no further significance,
but as the holiday offering,
it was intended to be the mercury theater,
his own radio version of dressing up in
a sheet and jumping out of a Bush and
saying boom.
16 years later, Orson
wells changed the story.
Here he is on the BBC.
The year is 1955 in fact,
we weren't as innocent as we meant to
be. When we did the motion broadcast,
we were fed up
with a way in which everything
that came over, new magic
box, the radio was being
swallowed. So in a way,
our broadcast was an assault on the, uh,
credibility of that machine.
We wanted people to understand that they
shouldn't swallow everything that came
through the tap.
So here are two ways to think
about the war of the worlds. One,
it was a smashing entertainment using
every trick they could think of including
inventing some new ones to scare you.
Silly master storytelling or or,
and it was, we're trying
to send you a warning.
Don't trust everything
you hear on the radio.
It's not always true to
which one was it. You think,
well, I asked the professor Jason
Lavilla [inaudible] me. Yeah, you,
Jason m, he's a radio historian
at the University of Maryland.
He says that what Welles understood was
that a newscast is often two things at
once in a newscast. You hear something
scary or disturbing sometimes,
but it's going to be told to
you in a way that's sues you,
meaning the authority of
the voice, the newscasters,
steady voice coming through the radio.
It will calm you like President
Roosevelt's famous fireside chat.
Hi Friend.
I want to prop for a few minutes with
the people of the United States about
banking. He's so calm, so in
charge. He says, Professor Olivia,
when you study the rhetoric
that Roosevelt used,
he really did convey two messages.
One we're in terrible danger.
And two, I've got it covered.
And that is the sort of the,
the authoritative voice coming out of
the darkness. This sort of invisible,
disembodied voice of the powerful man. Um,
the news anchor timber 22nd,
1940 and we'll see this
with Moreau on the rooftops.
Britain standing on a roof top during
the plane looking out over London,
straight in front of the, now it
was your two sounds and Justin Mama
are they on?
He's giving us a story of
an unfolding emergency,
I should think in a few minutes. There
may be a bit of shrapnel around here,
but his mastery of the information,
his mastery of his own voice,
his bravery on the scene,
you may be able to hear the sound of guns
off in the distance. Very thankfully.
Like someone kicking a tub.
This was the beginning of
the formatting of fear,
the formatting of crisis.
It's sort of a ritual where we're sort
of evoking a terrible danger and then
somehow assuaging those fears
through the performance of the news.
And so people go to the
news not to be afraid,
but to be afraid. And
then to be reassured.
Robert [inaudible], you file things
for the news. Yeah. Do you buy this?
That a news reporter does these two
things simultaneously scares and then
reassures and then scale. You never go,
you know, go cover the governor and say,
first I'm going to scare them, but
then I'm going to assuage them. You.
No one would do that. Why else would
you talk that way? I mean, not you. Oh,
but I mean
the, the, the, the anchors.
Well, sometimes you actually,
th th the form in of the news is a,
because the guy is always
there because he's an anchor.
That's what the word means.
It is a reassuring thing to see them
night after night to telling and telling.
But Loving Leo says that the real genius
of the war of the worlds was that wells
put you into a newscast where you
expect anchors to anchor and you expect
reporters to report. And then he
kills the reporter and the anchor,
and suddenly you're left all by yourself
in your own living room all alone.
Okay.
That is exactly right. The moment
of the war of the worlds broadcast,
which still frankly terrifies me.
It's this moment, right? Yeah.
It's like some head on the
tell you to play by the woods
running every way coming this
way down by 20 yards by, right.
It's like that silence is
terrifying. No anchor, no reporter,
no one to reassure you. Okay,
but forgetting that for a moment.
What about his second lesson that he
had to teach us the thing about don't
believe the radio. What
about that? Did it work?
Well, professor at Leo says, if that
is really what wells was trying to do,
if you believe that, well
then he failed. Actually,
he worse than failed the war of
the worlds. Not once, not twice.
We've shown you three broadcast tonight.
It was so good at grabbing an audience
and sucking them in that the wills
formula, you might call it,
the newscast that scares you enough to
keep you listening has been adopted by of
all folks. News
right now at 11 at night of shopping
during the to a night of fear,
swarming over boardrooms, flooding,
cities and towns, Muslim immigrants,
teens, texting and driving.
It's a deadly mint terror in the
toilet and sink holes and landslides,
python in the clot,
a rabid baby go terrorists
working at one of our airports.
So many newscasts tease you with
things that aren't quite true.
Terror in the toilet. Pythons
in the potty mean it may be,
there will be true snake somewhere near
a toilet tree facility of some kind.
But it probably wasn't the python
and it probably wasn't your toilet,
but you don't know that.
You want to hear that it belongs to Mrs.
James C McGillicuddy of 2114 beauday
boulevard and not you. So you,
you want to be reassured and so
you listen and so you fall in.
And if Orson Welles retelling a Martian
invasion story by hg wells at most
people already knew if he could grab us
and then if they could do it again in
Ecuador and then if they can do it again
in Buffalo, what does that tell you? It
tells you that we can't help ourselves,
even if the headline is slightly
preposterous, even if it's slightly scary,
even if it's slightly false,
we will listen.
The fear that these broadcasts generate
now suck us in and you'd think that 70
years later we'd be more
sophisticated and critical.
When the local newscaster tells us that
there's something we're feeding our
children that could kill them in,
they'll tell us after the
news the way I still listen.
I'm a media critic and I still wait
through the commercials to see what is it
that I'm doing to kill my child.
Even if it's really implausible,
your shoelaces will kill
you after this beat method.
I somehow it gets me every time.
Yeah, and wells knew.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Radiolab is produced by
[inaudible] Miller, Tony Field,
Rob Christensen and Ellen horn
production support from Heather Radke,
Michael Orion, McManus, Laura Vitale,
Ariel Lasky, Soren Wheeler, Linda Everts,
the rest of Anderson San and Todd,
Molly bloom, Bradley Campbell,
and Amata Espinosa. Special
thanks to Chris Worthington,
Tom Keith, Zoe Keating, Tony Ball,
Michael Grand Champ. Tom Campbell,
Joel Bevilacqua, Laura the Talle, Oliver
Conan, Nadya Reiman, Roberto Williams,
Lorraine Maddix, Scott
Goldberg, Andy Lancet,
the motor Tomo and Charles Nutella.
Original music for this hour was
provided by cellist, Zoe, Quito.
Check Checkout Zoe
keating.com you'll think of
before we close our show today,
I just want to remind you that
anything that you heard today,
anything you've ever heard on radio lab
can be found@radiolab.org that is our
address. And while you're there, I
would encourage you to email us radio
lab@wnyc.org is our email address. I'm
Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thank you so much for coming
and thank you for listening.
[inaudible].